hello i wanted to be the first to
congratulate you
congratulations on making it through uh
the year
maybe fist bump if you're more
comfortable with that guys we did it
the worst year on record a literal
dumpster fire
in some kind of a tsunami situation it
just
kept coming even think about the fact
that it was a leap year i mean what a
slap in the face we had to take another
day
of this horrible year it just would not
stop and
every possible sense this year was too
long too bad too sad
and i want to forget about it forever i
say collectively
look let's erase it from the
subconscious let's tear it out of the
calendars
even vision shouldn't be described as 20
20. it's just you have good vision now
now guys the other thing i want to say
is that when exiting a bad year like
this
you have to be extra positive look we
need to start off on the right foot it's
important
to start 2021 off right because
otherwise it could be just as bad
as this year and that for me for many of
you i know
it's not an option so mark my words and
embarrass me with them later
2021 is our year and i look i want to
want to start off with a bang
look big announcement right off the bat
going daily boys
seven days a week or at least that's
what we're trying and to start
start it off look i've just heard if you
want to increase your odds
of new year's resolutions like this
actually sticking there's something
called
loss aversion that helps it improves
your odds of success
what is loss aversion torture
self-inflicted torture if you fail your
goal
so this can mean anything you know you
have to donate to a charity you hate you
have to
you know get tased shoot yourself with a
paintball gun but all the
all that pain that's temporary i had to
think i had to dig deep
what kind of pain would be forever what
would i really fear
and i came up with it ladies and
gentlemen if i miss an upload in january
of 2021 i will be going bald yes that's
right i will be shaving
all this off gone by the way
some people they have like good head
shapes for that yes
yes yes
me not so much it's it's unfortunate my
head is uh
weirdly large uncomfortably large
actually when you see it on my frame
i mean if you see it in person but
especially if this mask
is taken off i think the contrast would
be too much i actually ran a little ai
filter
to see what it would look like so you
guys could see my torture
ahead of time and i'm sure many memes
will be made of it if i actually have to
go through with this
so i'm going to try hard not to this is
this is what it looks like enjoy not
not going to happen though not going to
happen where it's not an option so
that's what i'm doing let me know in the
comments below what you're doing look
start 2021 off
aggressively go go in make a big goal
tell me if you're gonna do some loss
aversion too i think it'd be interesting
if as a community we're all
hurting ourselves if we didn't even go
through with our
you know gym membership plans book
reading goals whatever you have going on
in your life
but i wish you the best look i know i'm
a little bit cynical sometimes with
these
gurus looking at these scams but the
truth is i'm an optimist at heart and i
wish you
the very best of years 20 i'm not even
going to say it look
last year is gone long live 2021.
see you in the next one
[Music]